the United States economy gained
216,000 jobs unemployment cap kept
steady at an historic
3.7% there's no way to paint this as
anything but good by most metrics we use
to measure the health of the economy it
is measurably better under Biden than it
was under Trump so the media are
continuing to take this Victory lap
after Friday's historic jobs report but
a quick look under the hood reveals the
Ugly Truth here 10 out of the last 11
jobs reports were revised downward that
means lower numbers than initially
reported now what's the result that
means 439,000 fewer jobs in 2023 than we
were told about and since June full-time
jobs were down by 1.5 million but we
added 760 thou 769 th000 part-time
workers joining me now Larry Cudo Fox on
news contributor host of cudow on Fox
Business Larry um the people darn it
just don't understand how good this
economy is for them translate
please well you've had a lot of downward
revisions it's very
unusual uh
20% 20% of the jobs growth in 2023 last
year has now been revised out
443,000 jobs guess is more is coming
when the so-called Benchmark revisions
come a lot of this by the way is coming
out of small businesses uh there's
something called a birth death measure
I'm not going to go into it the point is
household employment in December fell by
700,000 that's mostly small businesses
and the model that the Bureau of Labor
Statistics uses that is the birth of new
businesses versus the death of new
business that model's completely out of
whack just completely out of whack and
we didn't get those jobs in the first
place and the economy is not as strong
so that's the first point now Larry Paul
Krugman your buddy from the times is
celebrating a problem solved
watch could there be a recession in
2024 who knows economists have a perfect
track record on predicting recessions
which is we've never been wrong
inflation is definitely basically a
solved
problem it's all solved Larry just like
the border is almost solved
right well look it on this one there's a
bigger disagreement look inflation has
come down in recent months there's no
question about that but the trouble is
over the last three years the CPI has
gone up by
177% here's the issue politically and
economically we have an affordability
crisis because wages have only gone up
by
14% so real wages worker wages middle
class wages after inflation have come
down by 3% here's another way of looking
at it average weekly earnings okay was
$399 when Joe Biden uh took office and
the most recent number is
$380 so for 3 years
middle class folks have seen a decline
of 19 bucks or roughly 5%
4.7% that's the affordability problem
prices of groceries electricity even
gasoline uh inflation has come down the
rate of inflation but prices continue to
rise over the period the legacy of high
inflation continues wages have not kept
up and that's why you see these polls
there was another one out to today
rasmason you know 40 45% of the people
think they're worse off than they were 3
years ago they are worse off Jo bid's
problem yeah they are they are worse off
and the people AR the people are simply
not buying any of this Spin and they're
actually smarter than the Democrats uh
believe Larry great to see you thank you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else
El